roger waters an activist and founding
member of rock band pink floyd for more
on this roger thanks for coming on the
program good to have you with us tonight
um how concerned are you that this
verdict may not go in julian assange's
favor and he might face extradition
i'm extremely concerned because clearly
it's a kangaroo court has nothing to do
with justice or the arguments provided
or anything else
and it always has beaten
right from the beginnings so i'm i'm
deeply deeply concerned i just i
couldn't watch your uh that read that
clip of the people outside the court
because i'm not getting a picture here
but i heard everything they had to say
and and
everybody that i listen to is is making
complete sense you know this this is an
absolute nonsense that this man has been
locked up for a single day whether it's
in the ecuadorian embassy or in belmarsh
and this is this is one of the most
valuable human beings that we the human
race have
amongst us he is deeply deeply important
to the potential for this race to
survive on this planet in my view
and and and the way he's been treated is
obviously ludicrous has nothing to do
with law and order i i thought it was
interesting and i did manage to get some
stuff i didn't see a feed from the court
today but i got but i got a report
afterwards i thought it was interesting
that the justices there are two of them
i can't remember their names i haven't
taken them in yet
said well this is very complicated and
we're going to have to deliberate about
deliberate for some time before we uh
can make a judgment about before they
disappeared off to you know for their
dinner at boodles and large brandeds i
mean what a crock of this case is
absolutely clear and cut and dry and as
some chap in the crowd said just earlier
it should never have gone into a court
in the first place julian should never
have been incarcerated and he should be
set free immediately and it's a disgrace
and i too sir whoever you were in the
crowd i too am ashamed to be an
englishman on this day
i do appreciate it's an emotive topic
roger just do have to apologize to our
viewers there for the language though um
so excuse me
no worries no worries um throughout this
time of julian assange both in the
embassy and in prison indeed he has
built up a big base of support you for
one among them um if he does lose this
case or indeed if the case is uh sent
down to a judge uh
for
another look at this whole process um
what do you think a supporters should or
or can do in that case
they should do exactly what they're
doing outside the court in london today
they should remain confident that right
will
survive in this case they should go on
making as much noise as they can and
they should try and persuade their
neighbors and their uncles and aunts and
grandmas and grandpas and everybody that
they know to take to the streets to
protest it because this is one of the
most disastrous things that has ever
happened in the in the united kingdom
and and so it has to be resisted with
all possible measures
by as many people as we can get involved
it is a disgusting miscarriage of
justice let us not forget that the
reason that this was being appealed in
court by the united states of america
was because
vanessa beritzer the judge in the case
against julian was so
mealy-mouthed in her judgment
if she'd listen to the evidence and if
she was a proper judge and if she made a
proper judgment she would have said
there is no case to answer case
dismissed set the prisoner free she
didn't she said i'm a little bit worried
that the americans might be really
hurried to him and he might kill himself
and so
on those grounds i'm not going to allow
him to be extradited which was obviously
i'm not going to say cross croc of
whatever it was that i said before that
you objected to but it's ludicrous the
whole thing is completely ludicrous
julian should be sick and but what this
does mean of course is that if this
judgment goes against julian then the
defense will get to appeal and it will
go to the supreme court wherever that
now exists it used to be the house of
lords i don't know what it is in england
now
and the defense will get a chance to
challenge all
the ludicrous nonsense that's gone up
until this point and also it will give
more time uh for the voices in the choir
and the crowd to swell and for us to all
agree with jeremy corbyn who to his
eternal credit was outside the court
today uh on behalf of julian assange for
all of us for our voice to grow in power
and for the powers that be to start to
tremble in front of us which is what
they should have been doing up until now
how credible do you think our assurance
is coming from the united states that
assange if extra righted will not be
held in the strictest conditions um or
may even be allowed to serve as jail
sentence in australia which he is of
course a national of do you think
there's any truth to those assurances
obviously not they're lying through
their teeth look at guantanamo bay ask
shaka arma my friend ask anybody who has
been in the hands of the u.s judiciary
um
at any point possibly since the second
world war with whom they did not
agree and you will find that there's no
justice to be found in the united states
in the last few months we've had a
number of quite astonishing revelations
hadn't we among them
allegations of a key witness apparently
lying in their testimony
that alleged
plan by the cia to kidnap assange even
to harm him in some way this has all
been quite shocking but it's not been
getting that much media attention has it
and even if julian assange
is set free if the judge is throughout
this case
um do you think his safety uh will still
be at risk
of course it will
yeah good good point thank you for
bringing up the media why do you think i
get most of my news from rt because the
mass media western mass media is not to
be trusted and they and they appear
entirely disinterested in the rule of
law
most of them probably never heard of
magna carta or habeas corpus or any of
the basic tenets
of english law that developed in the
13th century and that we've been trying
to abide by ever since and it's all
being thrown out of the window now
on the altar of neoliberal capitalism
and that is why julian assange is in
prison because he's interfering with
their cunning plan to steal the planet
sort of rape it to death and then
destroy it
so we so you know our hearts go out to
stella morris and to the rest of his
family and to all of his supporters and
we and we we are not going on it
anywhere at all and our voice is going
to get louder and louder and louder
until julian assange is set free i can
promise you that i don't know if that
answers your question i'm so angry and
i'm so and i'm so disgusted with the
united kingdom
and with the government of the united
kingdom they should have stepped in
months ago we marched from the
australian embassy
to parliament square and made speeches
in february last year 2020
and at that point i thought you know
how have they got the balls
to just keep doing what they're doing
obeying their masters in washington dc
being poodles boris johnson and the rest
of them
well now i'm finding out how they do it
they do it because it feathers their
nest as well and um i i really don't
know what else to say i'm feeling a bit
sort of
um not incoherent exactly but i am
consumed
with horror of what's going on well i
was i did a radio program last night and
john shipton was on it and he was
extremely eloquent
and i asked him how he how he manages
his grief
and and he was absolutely he was so
moving to listen to he says well he he
puts it to one side as it goes through
his life and his life is entirely
devoted to the freeing of his son so he
can go home to his wife and children and
john says that late at night he might
have a glass of wine and he may
at that point or whiskey and he may
retreat
into his melancholy
and i felt my heart lurch in my chest as
i listened to this man saying this and
it
and i felt his melancholy
hit me
like a hammer blow on my chest you know
so
again i don't know what why am i getting
emotional because it's an extremely
emotional subject
you know
if the future of all of us and all of
our children and grandchildren hangs
upon this
court case if they destroy the fourth
estate which is what they're trying to
do by destroying assange they destroy
the world
that's it we're done if we no longer
have a voice we're done and if they
destroy assange
they will have destroyed the most
important voice of the 21st century
roger thanks so much for your time here
at art international we'll be keeping an
eye obviously on the developments at the
uk high court and we'll be good to have
you on again once a decision has been
made one way or another roger walters
there thanks so much
anytime